comme chaque année à cette époque
salvador dali revient d'un séjour à new
york il a bien voulu nous recevoir dans
l'appartement qu'il occupe dans un grand
hôtel parisien
lors de ces césure dans la capitale
avant de regagner dans quelques semaines
sa villa à cadaquès en espagne je suis
très heureux de vous recevoir un nouveau
pic à la caisse vous marrez sollicités
c'est une interview que nous avons avec
lui à propos de cet escroc merveilleux
que vous avez vu dans mon jardin
il est alors tout ce qui vous intéresse
à propos de ce cargo
j'ai tout plein de répondre 8
ça va être le sujet d'une contrainte ce
que j'aimerais mettre métal et une
certaine année de leur cas qu'est-ce qui
vous enfoncer encore je considère que
lorca devient plus important que d'être
en manque dans sa poésie est vraiment
dans la poule nord quand il a fait des
choses tellement sublime carelman ne
pouvait pas aller plus loin
tandis qu il a été fauché et mailhac et
qui est tragiquement au moment où il
commençait à avoir créé des shaders
capra et la grande rage ils disent c'est
que leur cattrall a été arrêté par sa
vie personnellement je pense que vous
êtes l'un des plus grands dessinateurs
que le monde ait connue qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
ça c'est déjà visionner la modestie
n'est pas une spécialité et
mais je pense pas je pense que à côté de
grands de notre renaissance médecins ne
valent à peu près rien maintenant dans
mon époque certainement l'issue de leurs
meilleurs décima de tout ce qui existe
je trouve au projet que je reste au
moins à paris et presque tous les jours
il y aura des événements extraordinaires
mais cette fois ci l'originalité de ces
événements c'est qu'il ne comporteront
absolument aucun genre d'excentricité
parce qu'ils jettent ou même un
excentrique à je suis les deux jeux ne
reposera je suis excentrique et
concentré maintenant je me sente
reçurent le patronage d'ingres et la
façon la plus originale de mon
comportement
c'est d'être concentré cette fois ci est
bas exemple